foreign
holding out hope for a recovery these
days fruit seller Mrs Guan has few
customers but she's keeping her shop in
Beijing open and hoping the upcoming
Lunar New Year will bring some good
fortune tell you later businesses like
restaurants are doing much better
nowadays there are more customers seized
a government East kovic 19 policies but
I am selling fruit and nuts and sales
are still not good these things are not
daily necessities and since people don't
have spare money they are more careful
with spending
a widespread covid-19 outbreak in China
in recent weeks has crippled consumer
spending millions of people have caught
the virus or stayed at home in the hope
of avoiding it the government says
everything is under control but there
are signs its rapid dismantling of
pandemic policies last month is
undermining the economic rebound exports
fell in December and factory production
shrank the most since long-term
lockdowns eight months earlier
in some places frustration is boiling
over
oh my God
[Applause]
at this Factory in central China police
confronted workers who were protesting
against layoffs and low wages
analysts say that China's covid-19
challenges have Global implications as
some of the world's biggest companies
from automakers to smartphone makers are
facing disruptions to their Chinese
production lines
apple is reported to be accelerating
plans to shift some of its operations to
India and Vietnam supply chain analysts
say that's set to become a growing Trend
it's sold up there you can predict it's
not going to be predictable that's the
that's the problem that bothers everyone
and if you just try to draw a contrast
between China and let's say even in many
countries in Southeast Asia their
policies are much more predictable they
are not tickling they have not been
taking such an extreme measure to to
control government and their practice
actually basically are more in nigh of
the western companies
economists are forecasting a longer-term
turnaround many predict that after
covid-19 infections have peaked China
could still achieve annual growth of
almost five percent but for businesses
that rely on Chinese spending and
Manufacturing a long-term recovery may
be too long to wait
Richard Kimber Al Jazeera in Hong Kong